president Trump waxes philosophic on his
big beautiful wall we will analyze the
long tradition of this feat
conservatives and Philistine liberals
then independent Democrat presidential
candidate Howard Schultz calls the green
New Deal immoral Cory Booker says poor
people shouldn't eat meat and we asked
do animals have feelings do white
teenage boys we will we will ask the
important questions I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
if you hadn't seen it the cover of
Esquire is causing a lot of mayhem and
chaos because it features a white
teenage boy in Middle America people are
outraged the usual suspects are all
feigning indignation at people want him
off the cover they think it's awful to
have a teenage boy in the cover this
gets to a central bias a central
condemnation of the left we'll get to it
by the end once we talk about whether
animals have feelings we can figure out
if white teen boys do too but first with
all the recent news about online
security breaches it is hard not to
worry about where your data go making an
online purchase or simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk you are being tracked by social
media sites marketing companies and your
mobile and Internet provider which is
why I decided to take back my privacy
with express VPN expressvpn has easy to
use apps that runs seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
takes only one click expressvpn secures
and anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address protecting yourself
with expressvpn costs less than seven
dollars a month that is so much less
than a cup of coffee it I don't even
know what an actual comparison would be
protect your online activity today find
out how to get three months for it
expressive VPN calm slash michael mi CH
AE l that's e XP re SS VPN comm slash
michael mi CH AE l for three months free
with a one-year package visit expressvpn
comm slash michael to learn more got to
take back that privacy before we get to
whether teenage boys have feelings or
not teenage white boys let's talk about
an overgrown teenager white boy
President Donald Trump who remains on
the warpath we talked about this
yesterday he's having a very good start
to his week he's had a very good
previous week and he just keeps on doing
it keeps on winning and there is even
more good news now so we talked about
good potential news from his
a cabinet meeting will go through that
cabinet meeting today we went talked
about the rally down in El Paso we
talked about how he's winning in public
opinion but now he's even got some more
trolling if you looked at his Twitter
account this morning he was referring to
the Senate investigation into his
improprieties with Russia and he tweeted
out not a Daily wire clip not a fox news
clip he tweeted out an MSNBC clip to
celebrate this news exclusive reporting
on the Senate Intelligence Committee
their investigation into Russian
election interference and what they have
and have not uncovered NBC's Ken Delaney
and has just jumped in front of a camera
to join me with his new reporting so Ken
what are you hearing what are you
learning
Holly after two years and interviewing
more than 200 witnesses the Senate
Intelligence Committee has not uncovered
any direct evidence of a conspiracy
between the Trump campaign and Russia
that's according to sources on both the
Republican and the Democratic side of
the aisle Hallie and careful viewers and
readers will note that Senator Richard
burr the chairman of the Intelligence
Committee who leaves this probe
essentially said that in an interview
with another network last week but what
I've been doing since then is checking
with my sources on the Democratic side
to understand the full context of his
remarks because that was essentially a
partisan comment from from one side but
this is a bipartisan investigation and
what I found is that the Democrats don't
dispute that oh like a so president
Trump included that entire clip from
MSNBC because the schadenfreude is so
much better when your opponents are
saying that what they are saying is the
Senate Intelligence Committee was
investigating Trump's links to Russia
Russian interference whatever they came
up short and now you could say well the
Senate is run by Republicans and so it's
no surprise that they came up short but
what they're saying on MSNBC to their
credit they're at least admitting it is
that they spoke to sources on both sides
of the aisle on that committee the
Republicans said the investigation
turned up nothing the Democrats said the
investigation turned up nothing
now we predicted that this would happen
weeks and weeks and months and months
ago of course but we also saw that this
was happening in particular right now
week when Adam Schiff that Democrat
congressman who's running all the
investigations when he started shifting
his focus away from Russia on to Donald
Trump's financial interests you realized
they were coming up with nothing on
Russia Russia was the story if they
could have said ah dumb from visited
Russia he ate borscht ten years ago if
they could have linked him they would
have stuck on that story but they can't
they came up with nothing and so now
they're saying well if if Vladimir Putin
is not buying off the Donald Trump we
want to make sure that nobody else is
either so we're gonna look into all of
his financial records since forever and
then we're going to make sure nothing is
improper there now the reason for this
of course is that Donald Trump is a very
wealthy man he has about a zillion
businesses some of them succeeded some
of them went under any guy who's worked
for a long time in business is gonna
have very complex financials and they're
hoping to look in and find something
untoward especially if you worked in
real estate development in New York
you've probably dealt with some shady
characters so now they're just trying to
rummage through Trump's trash and find
anything that might be scintillating for
for gossipers anything that might be
scintillating to try to bring him down
but on Russia what if they got thus far
nothing now we can wait for the Muller
report maybe Bob Muller found something
that nobody else was able to find maybe
he found the smoking gun of Donald Trump
colluding with boris and Natasha but
right now as we as we have said since
the beginning since 2016 it's just not
looking like it so the substantive
question president Trump is obviously
winning on this one issue that has
dogged him you can tell he sort of let
it get to him because it'll just tweet
out no collusion crazy investigations he
mentioned in the State of the Union now
on the substantive question will
president Trump take a deal on the wall
or will he shut down the government so
he shut down the government and he said
we need to get 5.7 I believe billion
dollars for wall funding now 5.7 billion
dollars is not nearly enough to build
the wall it's only enough to build a
couple hundred miles of new
wall then the government was shut down
long is shut down ever then the
government reopens and he says I'm gonna
open it for three weeks but if we don't
get to the negotiating table if you
don't give me money for the wall then
I'm going to shut the government down
again so will he shut it down
I don't think so I don't think he's
going to I don't know how important it
is that he does actually well it depends
on how else he can get the money I think
he likes his high approval rating I
think he likes that right now he is
seriously winning there's a lot of
momentum in the public opinion sphere
for him so I don't think that he wants
to kill that approval rating and halt
that momentum by shutting down the
government again also what would he be
shutting it down for he needs to build
the wall he needs to build the wall if
he can't do it he's toast in 2020 but if
he can do it another way he should so
the deal on the table that has been
struck by legislators that they're now
bringing to Donald Trump asking his
opinion on takes the amount of requested
money down from 5 billion dollars all
the way down to 1 point 3 7 5 billion
for a wall that is a fraction of what
they offered him for the wall obviously
a lot less than he asked for and they
won't be able to build much wall for
this what do they be able to build 50
miles maybe of wall so why would Donald
Trump take the deal there's one really
big reason why he would take the deal
and the reason is this if he gets even
one point four billion or one point 375
billion for the wall he can come back
and destroy the Democrats fundamental
argument which is that walls are immoral
which is that walls don't work that's
been their argument now since the
beginning walls are immoral ineffective
and they cost too much money and what
President trumpet can say if he takes
any amount of money if they give him 50
bucks out of their pockets he can say
well if walls are immoral then you all
just committed an immorality if walls
are ineffective then you all just gave
me money for nothing and if walls are
too expensive than you all just wasted
the people's money even if it's only
some of the people's money even if it's
only a tiny fraction of it so I think
there actually is an argument to take a
deal even if the deal isn't gonna build
a whole lot of wall because then what is
there
argument when he comes back and says we
need more money for more wall are they
gonna say it's immoral is it well you
all did it already I mean this argument
was so effective for Republicans when
they pointed to Chuck Schumer and said
hey Chuck Schumer in 2006 you paid for
the wall now we never got built or in a
lot of places it wasn't built but you
paid for it so what's changed now now
some Democrats in the House and the
Senate were not susceptible to this
attack because they weren't there in
2006 their relative newcomers but now if
he gets all of them on the record as
paying for this wall what argument do
they have I'm not sure the the thing
that needs to be addressed of course is
how does he build the rest of the wall
if he just builds 50 miles of wall he's
toast in 2020 his his supporters will
abandon him if he can't build more than
50 miles of wall what are we doing what
are we even doing here it's his
signature central campaign promise so
President Trump all of this swirling
around in his head he finally addressed
the question over whether he would
accept the deal or not at a cabinet
meeting that's also less expensive to
build much better that's a good
combination of events because it was
crazy what they were putting up the
walls that they were building were so
unattractive and so ugly
that walls got bad names okay if that
means anything but there was so ugly
with rusted steel and big ugly plates on
top that we're all tin cans it's called
tin cans with a wavy because they heat
makes them expand and contract they
didn't can
I say why didn't you paint the steel
well sir we saved money by not painting
if I said yeah it's gonna rust you have
to pay I've never seen it I've ordered a
lot of steel I've never seen in my whole
life
still come to me that was unpainted so
he goes on like this for a little bit
you'll notice with the way he's talking
about the wall is not talking about it
in utilitarian terms he's not talking
about it even as a matter of cost he's
talking about it in strictly aesthetic
terms and here President Trump comes
from a long conservative tradition this
actually shows us a significant
difference between the right and the
left but first before we get into all of
that let's make a little money honey
when I travel I'm always walking around
a lot more than I do at home and it can
make my feet even my whole body ache you
might have noticed that too when you
travel and when you buy shoes maybe you
think that a high-end shoe will make
your feet feel great the truth is the
shoe is only as good as its insole and
as you get older maybe you're getting
those mystery aches and pains I
identifies about 150 years old so I get
a lot of them maybe you even have
plantar fascitis am i pronouncing that
sin sounds like kind of dirty I don't
know what that word or diabetes did you
know that the right shoe and so it can
make a huge difference that is why
you've got to check out portalis many
people are unaware that knee hip back or
even upper body muscle tightness and
other issues can stem from improper
alignment that all begins in the foot
specifically it's where you're just
looking at the alignment of your ankle
this is true for more than 80% of people
and very few people know that Portales
shoe insoles have impact the foot the
footwear industry with a revolutionary
innovation their insoles are different
than any other insole on the market they
unlock our true potential with
interconnectedness of the kinetic chain
between the foot ankle knees hips back
spine shoulders and neck Pro talus
insoles bridge the gap between custom
orthotics and over-the-counter cushioned
Inns inserts with over 1 million happy
customers and a 97% success rate for
talus insoles create a better connection
between your ankle and the rest of your
body portalis has over 100,000 positive
reviews they've shown to provide relief
from foot knee hip and back pain
including neuropathy neuromas many many
more
this week this week only my listeners
can save $30 on every pair of Pro talus
insoles at PR o tal us calm when
entering podcast 30 the number 30 at
checkout shipping is free if you buy two
or more pairs they will upgrade you to
free expedited shipping give Pro tellus
insoles to try experience the difference
more comfort more energy more life they
have a 90 day money-back hassle-free
guarantee you have nothing to lose
except the pain that is PR OT al us comm
promo code podcast 30 save $30 on every
pair of pro talus insoles so president
Trump is there at the cabinet meeting
talking about the wall and the way he's
talking about it is in aesthetic terms
he said the walls that they built before
the fences they built before were so
ugly they gave walls themselves a bad
name he set up at the top because the
steel was poor quality and it wasn't
painted it would start to tin-can it
would get waves throughout it it would
start to rust and and President Trump
was outraged they would start to rust
good steel it you should entrust you
should be able to paint it that way that
it won't rust I I love that he's
speaking in these terms this these
aesthetic terms these graphic terms show
a big difference with the left the left
tends to be strictly utilitarian and
conservatives are not I think in the
popular culture we get this backwards we
think of conservatives is the sort of
stodgy old man give reading The Wall
Street Journal just counting the dollars
in his bank account and can liberals
rather you know they're the artistic
ones man they've got such cool artistic
ideas in reality it's the reverse
because the left has very little
imagination the left has its ideology
it's got its science of politics its
science of history and it's trudging
along joylessly toward progressive
utopia but on the conservative side
conservatives have a more romantic view
of the world a more immense complex
intricate view of the world we have a
greater appreciation of mystery we look
at the world with greater awe and wonder
it's no coincidence that the big mack
daddy of conservative
the godfather of conservative thought
Edmund Burke was a proto romantic he
inspired the romantics here our main
conservative modern founder Edmund Burke
before he wrote reflections on the
revolution in France he was an aesthetic
philosopher he wrote an inquiry into our
ideas on the sublime and the beautiful
president Trump is gonna write the
revised and expanded edition I think
he's gonna write a sequel to that these
terms obviously President Trump has used
these a lot on the campaign trail one
thing that really set him apart from the
other candidates is the other candidates
where I'll be speaking in really dry
policy terms and president Trump would
paint a picture he would paint a picture
of John Kasich eating in a disgusting
manner say oh you ever seen the way that
guy eats it's disgusting
he just stuffs his face he's hovering
over the plate it's disgusting then
you'd have this image in your head you'd
have an image of a low-energy Jeb
what is it Low Energy VOC maybe like a
little atom with the electrons are dead
or so just kind of a guy's slumped sort
of like this little Marco he's always
sweating he's always thirsty so it gives
you this image of a nervous guy guy
reaching for water sweat pouring down
his face he was always painting pictures
and it created images that really stuck
so throughout that entire campaign when
he gave you a nickname when he gave you
a description it would really stick this
is a wonderful tool of conservatives and
of the right and we should use it all
the time we should use our vivid imagery
our appreciation of a world that is more
complex than some stupid little
manifesto you know then here's the whole
world in five bullet points according to
Karl Marx the conservative view is so
much richer than that we should use it I
mean this is part of what makes leftism
so inhuman leftism treats human beings
like material objects leftism says when
our material needs are satisfied
everything is great
so when Barack Obama was talking about
jihad in the Middle East he said all the
reason that these guys are committing
jihad
not because they're motivated by big
ideas it's not because they have a
perverse view of God and the divine and
the transcendent and the purpose of
their lives no no it's because they
don't have jobs it's because they can't
afford to buy iPods you know if these
guys in jihadi land if they could just
buy iPods and watch TV
oh then they'd be they'd be totally fine
then they would it's just we're just
automatics we're just a material fleshie
deterministic machines once you plug us
full of material then we don't have any
thoughts anymore we this is the idea of
the left that's unhuman they they don't
realize that human beings are not
primarily material creatures were
primarily spiritual and artistic
creatures GK Chesterton wrote about this
with the earliest men when you think
about the caveman what image comes into
your mind this sort of semi conscious
big eyebrows not very smart guy who's
dragging a club in one arm and his wife
in the other and he's dragging them
around and he's a brute and he's barely
he's got capable of reason and he's
barely recognizable to us because that
is the leftist view of what a human
being fundamentally is but we don't know
that the caveman carried a club around
we don't know that the caveman dragged
his wife by her hair we don't know
anything about the caveman other than
this that he was an artist chesterton
points this out the only thing we
actually know about cavemen is that they
painted drawings on cave walls little
animals in pigments that's what they did
the actually the only firm thing we can
say about our hominid at cave ancestors
is that they had an artistic sensibility
they wanted to reproduce their vision of
the world in art and they had an
abstract enough reason and then
sophisticated enough consciousness that
they were able to do that they were able
to see an animal in the field go into a
cave and by torchlight or whatever paint
the little animal
the cave they had a sophisticated enough
artistic sense that they could create
the pigment in which to paint the animal
that is a sophisticated creature that is
a creature so sophisticated he almost
looks like you and me turns out that our
ancestors may have had a lot in common
with us it turns out maybe the essence
of human Humanity is aesthetic and
conservatives really get this and even
President Trump I mean you know our
image of President Trump is that he's
walking around the field with a club in
one arm and his wife and the other arm
dragging her by the hair but in reality
when you actually listen to this guy
talk especially when he talks about
building especially when he talks about
his career he speaks in esthetic terms
so that's how he's viewing the wall
premiering it's a great way to view it
what about the deal itself we're going
because we're supplementing things and
moving things around and we're doing
things that are fantastic and taking
from far less really from far less
important areas and you think it's easy
we're building in the face of tremendous
obstruction and tremendous opposition
look at the comparison and just how when
he's talking about the wall itself -
when he's talking about how he's gonna
fund the wall he starts to say at the
ladder yeah well we're taking a lot of
money from different areas and frankly
everybody and it's going from an area
it'll be in another area
obstruction he clearly cares a lot less
about that I think he just wants to get
the thing built and so should he take
the deal or not well if he can take the
deal and then tie it around the
Democrats next that's fine if and only
if he can take the money from elsewhere
the senator Ted Cruz has a great idea of
where to get that money which is that
we've finally got El Chapo we're putting
him into an American prison so he's not
gonna break out this time he's gonna
break out like he did in Mexico and we
seized 14 billion dollars from him
President Trump only asked for five
billion for the wall how about we take
all that 14 billion
through asset forfeiture and then if you
did that you would not only be able to
build the wall you would make Mexico pay
for it you'd be able to make Mexico pay
for it without Mexico actually paying
for it so without making the Mexican
taxpayers pay for it or the Mexican
government you take like the worst
Mexican of all time and you just steal
all his money which he's given up now he
needs a prisoner he's not getting that
money back and so you take that money
you make Mexico pay for it and
specifically one of the main reasons we
need this wall is because drugs keep
pouring over the border this guy's
responsible for a lot of that take his
money and make him build the wall you
broke it you buy it it would be terrific
if we can do it whether the asset
forfeiture laws are such that that's
even possible he is up in the air
conservatives have been promoting this
idea for a long time it's not just Ted
Cruz or Donald Trump who can do it
maybe it gets challenged in court and
maybe it's tied up in court for a long
time it would be a great way to start
doing it though and in this very
whimsical way you could accomplish every
single one of the campaign promises in a
way that certainly not even president
Trump could have expected but president
Trump is not the only person who's upset
with Democrats these days for
obstruction or radicalism Democrat
Howard Schultz is also upset with the
Democrats and here is why in a CNN Town
Hall he's asked this question as a
lifelong Houstonian I've seen the
damages that hurricanes have caused to
my city and I watched as Harvey
continued in a devastating way that
damage so in the face of a warming
climate that leads to more powerful
storms how much of a priority would
climate change be to your administration
and what are some plans you have to
tackle that issue before we get to his
answer I would like to point this out
this is the trick that the left does all
the time he says as a native Houstonian
I have seen the damage that global
warming has done to my community I've
seen what these storms that are caused
by global warming I've seen what they do
and it's I've seen global warming up
close because of specific weather events
global warming is whether the climate or
is whether or not the climate because
when Amy Klobuchar gets covered in snow
and we mock her for saying globe
warming is happening they say weather is
not climate and then when this kid gets
up there and says there was a big storm
that affected Houston therefore that is
global warming all of the left applauds
and say yes that is that specific
weather event is the climate but only
that one because it confirms our biases
not the other specific weather events
that's not climate what you'd have to be
an idiot to think that those specific
weather events are climate which is it
you can it cannot be both you I know
they want it to be it's very convenient
when it's both is the premise here by
the way that before global warming there
was no such thing as hurricanes they
never know her first ever hurricane
happened in 1997 it was the first ever
hurricane ever recorded by human beings
we didn't even know what we thought the
gods were coming down they were so angry
with us because of all the rain no the
first at 1997 right when global warming
started that was the first hurricane no
of course you have to pick one or the
other
but for some reason conservatives let
the left get away with this they say
well the extreme storms well what about
the extreme blizzard up in Minnesota is
that global warming yet you cannot have
both ways so Howard Schultz answer this
question when I read the green New Deal
and I try and understand what they're
suggesting I don't understand how you're
going to give a job for everybody how
are you going to give free college to
everybody how you going to create clean
energy throughout the country in every
building of the land and then tally this
thing up with 32 trillion dollars on
Medicare for all that's about 40
trillion dollars plus we are sitting
ladies and gentlemen with 22 trillion
dollars of debt on the balance sheet of
America so once again not that I'm a
business person or or I'm an economist
and maybe an economist would disagree
with me but I think it's not it's
immoral to suggest that we can tally up
20 30 40 50 trillion dollars of debt to
solve a problem that could be solved in
a different way and now of course he's
right about this
the question is is this gonna help him
in his strategy to run as an independent
Democrat for president or is this gonna
hurt him I think it helps him this his
whole strategy is it he has to split the
Democrats he's got to split the
reasonable Democrats away from the
insane radical intersectional leftists
and then he's got a siphon some votes
off of Donald Trump and then he becomes
president now is this a likely strategy
see likely to become president no but
anything could happen but look never say
never when it comes to Donald Trump as
they say so I suppose there's a world in
which it does happen plus events change
everything so if Donald Trump goes
spiraling down for some reason he
actually has a pretty good chance of
doing it I don't think that Howard
Schultz is running a an intentionally
futile campaign I don't think he's
running just to show the strength of
possible third parties I don't think
that at all I think Howard Schultz is
running to win he knows that the odds
are stacked against him but he's gonna
put him in a play himself in a place
where if something goes wrong he could
theoretically become president now there
is an appetite out there for less crazy
Democrats they're genuinely is what
Ocasio cortes and the green New Deal
people try to insist is that the
American people broadly love the green
New Deal that's what they said they said
over 80% of Democrats and over 60% of
Republicans support the green New Deal
and what that's those statistics are
based on is a survey from Yale's Center
for climate change communication and
it's a totally bogus survey which polled
people who did not know what the green
new deal is have never heard of the
green new deal and when it asked them
about it basically just said hey the
green new deal is really great and it's
gonna be really really great and its
supporters say it's really really great
do you support it and then they were
shocked to find out that most people
supported that really great thing but
when people actually learn about what
the green New Deal is 88 percent of
American energy destroyed cost 40
trillion dollars that they're gonna pay
for by printing money out of
in air right out of the Federal Reserve
that it's gonna outlaw automobiles it's
going to outlaw planes it's going to
outlaw your house it's going to take
away your doctor and your medical care
it's going to take away unemployment
insurance it's going to force people
onto a backstop government job when
people find out about that the
popularity of the green New Deal
plummets to nothing so there is a pot
there is certainly an appetite out there
for a less crazy Democrat Howard Schultz
is filling that he's not a Republican
some people are trying to present him as
this conservative guy he's not at all he
really is a lifelong Democrat but
there's an appetite out there for less
insane Democrats same thing on abortion
there's a new survey out today from
YouGov it shows that two-thirds of
people who identify as pro-choice in
favor of abortion oppose third trimester
abortion so two-thirds of people who
think that they support abortion
actually are pro-choice think that after
whatever 24 26 weeks abortion should be
illegal to say nothing of Ralph Northam
the governor of Virginia's idea that
abortion should be legal after birth we
should be able to kill babies once
they've been born so there's a real
appetite out there Howard Schultz is a
tough dude he's not a squish he is
running to win he sees an opening for
himself I think it'll probably help
Republicans broadly but who knows and if
he is able to bring the Democrats back
to some modicum of sanity that would be
a great service to the nation but a guy
who is a squish is cory booker cory
booker is telling everybody not to eat
meat especially poor people we will get
to the democrats all trying to out woke
one another then we will ask do animals
have feelings then we will ask two white
teenage boys have feelings but first go
to daily wire.com if you are on daily
wire thank you very much you keep the
lights on you keep Kofi Fay in my cup if
you're not go over it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the end reclaim ensure
you get the Ben Shapiro show you have to
ask questions in the mailbag you get the
Matt Walsh o mail bags coming up
tomorrow get your questions in you get
to ask questions backstage we're doing a
lot of those now get
questions in the conversation you got
another Kingdom you get so much stuff
now and you get this
the leftist tears tumblr and by the way
if Howard Schultz does run hard for
president through the general and if he
spoils the election for Democrats and if
because of him Donald Trump gets
reelected we're gonna put out the
vintage leftist ears Pike Place roasts
it's gonna be some people say it's
bitter I think it tastes so so sweet
go over to daily wire calm and get it
we'll be right back
cory booker is a vegan today i guess of
course he is did anyone really think
otherwise all of these Democrat
candidates are trying to out woke one
another other than Howard Schultz who
basically is playing a different game he
says I'm not gonna out low call you
idiots I'm gonna run on my own ticket
and I'm gonna beat all of you because I
have a lot of money so we've got Camilla
Harris yesterday talking about how she
loves smoking pot and listening to Snoop
Dogg even though Snoop Dogg didn't come
out with his debut album until seven
years after Camilla Harris said that she
was smoking pot okay then you've got
bado O'Rourke writing his little diary
entries like a teenage girl
you've got Elizabeth Warren now
addressing an Indian group she's doing
it again she can't she appeared at
another Indian group and talked about
how important it is to support Indians
this is her white whale this is she
cannot give this up I think maybe for a
couple reasons one she lied about it for
so long that it's really hard for her to
stop lying about being Native American
and two because of her own sense of
virtue either the vote how she wants to
appear virtuous to her voters or even
her own sense of virtue to herself
because what she has done is lie about
her race for decades to her professional
advantage and actually to the
disadvantage of real Native Americans
and now in her mind and in the mind of
voters she hopes she's supposed to be a
really good virtuous person she's so
much better than mean bad guys like
Donald Trump
those are bad people but she's a good
person except it turns out she's not a
good person
she's a race fraud who disadvantaged
Native Americans to get ahead in her
career not a good person at least as bad
a person as the rest of us she's not
saint elizabeth she's not
holier-than-thou
she's a race fraud and so she can't get
over it she keeps going back she so let
me release DNA results see I'm right I'm
a good person I'm not a liar in a race
fraud I'm a good
person let me apologize to the Cherokee
Nation um see I'm a good I'm a good
belief that I'm a good person
she can't out woke this she's not this
is gonna dog her if she'd had an answer
on this she would have come up with one
already but she hasn't its dogged her
for a long time she made her teepee she
can lie in her teepee and now it's looks
like it's killed her presidential
campaign but she's gonna keep going back
to it it's gonna keep being funny
and now to out woke them all Cory Booker
is focusing on being vegan these are the
thing you'll notice about all of this
smoking pot listening to Snoop Dogg
writing little diary entries about your
feelings trying on new identities trying
on racial minority identities that you
don't even really have but you just want
to kind of craft that identity being
vegan what do all these things have in
common these are all phases that
teenagers go through teenagers go
through all of these phases some more
than others
it's because Democrats these candidates
don't have a serious sense of purpose
they don't have a serious sense of
maturity they don't have a serious sense
of identity so they just keep cycling
through these phases like teenagers
they're behaving in a shallow sophomoric
way they don't they just never got to
the next stage of mental and spiritual
development and so they just keep trying
on these different phases these little
fads here is Cory Booker Cory Booker
whining as he usually does defending
veganism against his critics just is
heartening to hear somebody in this day
and age in the United States of America
say basically implicate that gay men are
not meant that they're not guys that was
the wrong clip maybe maybe you know is
the wrong clip that is Cory Booker
talking about another rumor and actually
really the woke prize of them all there
are there have been public rumours for a
long time that Cory Booker is gay and
he's always denied it then he came out
with his bombshell story last week Cory
Booker has a girlfriend
you know she's living up in Canada none
of us have ever seen her but yeah he has
got a girlfriend I don't know who cares
I don't really care if Corey Booker is
gay or not but that would be the woke
prize that would be V if a candidate
came out as openly gay during the
primary could you ever out woke that the
only way to outlook that would be to
come out as transgender or something
which I guess any of them could do at
any given time but this is what cory
booker is doing he's leaning in all this
way whenever he's asked the question
about being gay he says well so what if
I am maybe maybe I am gay
I'm not gay but what if I am and he's
trying is pushing this line i don't know
whether cory booker is gay or not
frankly i don't know if cory booker is a
vegan or not but they're just trying to
check all of the behavioral boxes what
they view as the ideal behavioral boxes
of the left have a non-traditional diet
have a non-traditional sexuality smoked
non-traditional drugs have a
non-traditional ethnicity even if you
have to make one up at a pole cloth like
liz warren that is what they're all
aiming for and you'll notice what none
of this has anything to do with is
public policy none of this has anything
to do with actually doing the job of
president or even their own experience
in life they're just talking about
little fads that teenagers do the latest
one now being veganism this does raise a
real question which is what is the
morality of veganism do animals have
feelings as was recently asked in an
article I think in the Atlantic or
animals morally significant this article
was really good I encourage people to
read it every so often you know Kate
Flanagan always publishes good stuff in
the Atlantic and she's the one person
who does and then all the other stuff in
the Atlantic is trash I barely read it
anymore except every so often they
publish a good piece so this one asked
do animals have feelings and they talk
about the Janes
in India and these this group of people
who has a religious devotion to animals
and how they understood long before the
West did long before those idiot
Westerners these Eastern spiritual
people realize
that animals are really super conscious
and they suffer all the time and they're
just as complex as humans and we can
never even look at them the wrong way
here is the sort of fake science that
they use in throughout this article in
the article they say quote in one
experiment honeybees were attracted to a
boat at the center of a lake which
scientists stocked with sugar water when
the bees flew back to the hive they
communicated the boats location with
waggle dances the hives other bees would
usually set out immediately for a newly
revealed nectar load but in this case
they stayed put as though they'd
consulted a mental map and dismissed the
possibility of flowers in the middle of
a lake other scientists were not able to
replicate this result but different
experiments suggest that bees are
capable of consulting a mental map in
this way what because all they want this
is the new move that everyone wants to
do they want to prove that animals are
just as conscious as we are they
anthropomorphize animals because they
they can't stand the idea that man has
dominion over the land and the sea they
can't stand the idea that man is
superior to the other animals no no it
had we're all just the same thing we're
basically just slightly more advanced
honeybees but even though the way that
they say it they look at their
imagination the imagination of these
scientists and especially this writer
the honeybees were communicating this
really sophisticated way this location
far far away at a lake in the middle of
a boat and the other honeybees they were
all going to go over there to get the
sugar water
they didn't of course but that's just
because why because they could they had
thought about it they were thinking
about it really complexly and then but
then they didn't do it because they
rejected it they had some meetings and
they held a couple elections probably
and I don't know they they built up huge
Sybil and then they just didn't do it
and scientists weren't able to replicate
any of the stuff we're saying but
they're really really really smart you
guys this is the product of I think an
idolatry of scientific materialism this
is a product of an idolatry of processes
of natural
evolution people who want to erase the
distinction between man and beast but
human beings have intellect and will we
are different we are categorically
different from animals this is not
popular according to modern orthodoxy
but it remains true and attempts to
present some other idea or to upend that
always end up in silly mental gymnastics
and unscientific conclusions such as
this but it says a lot about our society
our modern material a secular society
that we are so desperate to make
ourselves the same as animals we want to
level ourselves down in this
egalitarianism not just of the species
but of all the species we will level
ourselves down we want to
anthropomorphize and exalt and raise up
animals this is pagan and there is a
reason that they're comparing this to
the James or ancient Indian religions
this is paganism and we have a new
paganism on our hands because we are
rejecting the natural order and all of
the philosophical and theological and
scientific fruits of our civilization so
I don't think animals have feelings do
white men have feelings there's a
wonderful piece in Esquire I called the
life of an American boy at 17 and the
Big D this is so awful
this piece talks about a white teenage
boy in middle America he is on the cover
of Esquire how dare they how dare you
put a white team white teenage boys are
the worst white teenage boys are the
only group in America that the culture
permits and actually encourages us to
hate and condemn you remember with those
Covington boys who were waiting for
their school bus in DC everyone jumped
on them tried to turn them into awful
racer old bigots whatever then it turned
out it was exactly the opposite and the
senior this culture writer at BuzzFeed
and Helen Peterson said well you can
understand why that face caused a
visceral reaction in so many he's a
young white guy and one young white guys
are the worst there was that piece in
the Yale Daily News about how young
white guys with brown hair are evil and
we should ruin their lives that's the
culture that
we live in now actually the the reaction
that this piece has prompted is evidence
that the piece is urgent and timely the
big line now they say is how dare you
run that cover during Black History
Month do you know you can only do black
things during Black History Month you
can't do any non black things during
Black History Month you have to wait
until white middle-class teenage boy
month to run the cover of that kid on
Esquire I don't know when white
middle-class teenage boy month is it's
not as though Esquire doesn't put black
men on the cover of their magazine they
do it all the time
in just the last year or two they've put
on a dress Elba Pharrell Chadwick
Boseman Donald Glover plenty of day you
don't need you you don't only limit
black men to one month you know you can
have black men in any month of the year
it's okay they're not outlawed during
all the other eleven months this is how
the piece begins it says Ryan Morgan is
17 and happy to be a guy to be a girl
with me and he'd have to deal with a lot
more drama he'd likely have to deal with
Mean Girls and he doesn't end up a mom
he could end up a mom rather which he
doesn't ever want because being a mom is
hard probably the hardest job in the
world
also he might not think football was as
interesting he isn't sure what would be
interesting if it isn't football then he
hasn't interested other than that he
doesn't think there are too many reasons
it would be better to be a guy than a
girl unless you're from the Middle East
or maybe the inner-city this is a
profile of the way that a 17 year old
boy in America is thinking so it has all
of these things
he seems like a perfectly moderate kid
by the way it's not like he's some guy
wearing a trump hat every single place
he goes he's saying being a mom is the
hardest job in the world the reason he
wants to be a guy is because that's who
he is he can't really imagine being a
girl but in the abstract he doesn't
think it would be terribly to be a girl
unless you're not living in Western
civilization where it actually is pretty
terrible to be a girl the editor of the
magazine sent out a letter explaining
why he put this piece because he knew
that there would be pushback and the
piece that he wrote then that letter is
called why your ideological echo chamber
isn't just bad for you it's also bad for
your kids and it is this is really bad
we live
very confusing culture where we're told
to judge people only on their character
not on the color of their skin or
superficial physical characteristics
we're also told that white teenage boys
are the worst people ever the embodiment
of evil other than maybe grown straight
white men who think that they're men
that's the top of the intersectional
pyramid but they're just awful people
accept but don't judge anyone on their
skin or on their sex
we're told that men and women are so
exactly the same that there is no
difference whatsoever men can be women
women can be men sex barely exists and
then we're also told if you treat women
within a certain way if you don't if you
don't treat men and women exactly the
same you know if you if you can never
hit a woman now of course we all know
you can never hit a woman you can't hit
a woman because men and women are
different but if men and women are
exactly the same why can't you hit a
woman if there's no physical or
spiritual difference whatsoever
we're told a lot of confusing messages
we're told that everyone is entitled to
his opinion think outside the box
diversity tolerance and then as this
article shows if you're a white teenage
boy who holds an opinion you're told
shut up you have privilege you're not
entitled to have an opinion shut your
mouth check your priveledge and stop
talking these are very confusing
messages a very confusing time a very
confusing leftist culture that gave it
to us the Esquire piece beautifully
embrava Lee analyzes that I encourage
you all to read it's a very long piece
and you should read it and post about it
too because it drives the left crazy
kudos to Esquire Squires not exactly a
conservative magazine but they're at
least dealing honestly with this
question so my hat goes off to them I
tipped my mag ahead to them okay that's
our show
get your mailbag questions and come back
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Moses as the Michael Nolan show I'll see
you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19